[Music]
hello YouTube chairs levers in my
friends this is grunge in here welcome
to the sixth episode of most attacking
jazz game now there are hardly any
professional chess player who doesn't
know the name of VA this Chinese prodigy
recently comes into the limelight when
he played the game of the century last
year 2015 and he has a dream chess
profile like he broke many records
including fastest player to reach try
600 as well as 2718 so you can see the
potential of this guy and I think in
next 5 years is going to be a great
contender for the World Championship
matches in the modern times he is
considered as a Michael tall and if you
are looking for an attacking chess games
then you certainly have to look to the V
use games okay enough talk about VA
let's start the game so this game was
played in the Year 2015
where VA he was white and his opponent
was somewhat low rated like 300 points
lower than him
so obviously VA has to play very
attacking chance and indeed we are going
to see some great fireworks in this game
he start with the movie 4 and his
opponent responded with the Moosey file
so we have a Sicilian defense and after
Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captures Knight
captures here black has two good replies
a6 leads to the con variation of the
Sicilian
where n c6 which is played in this game
leads to the thigh mono or the pulse in
variation of the Sicilian okay we
continue here with the move Knight to c3
is up and responded with the move Queen
to c7 and after the move Bishop to e3
black the stop any Knight inclusion with
the move a six now the most frequently
played systems here are Bishop to e2
which leads to the classical variation
and also the move f3 and Queen to d2
which leads to the Yugoslav attack but
we also known for playing some random of
mid lines and in this guy
he played a sideline that is Quint Webb
three well the idea is very simple white
wants to castle as quickly as possible
on the Queen side and just finish the
development now it is very interesting
to see the blacks mental position over
here because from the game I found out
that decided to play very aggressively
but it doesn't turns out very well
so black decided to continue here with
the move Knight to e5 attacking the
Queen Queen to g3 in other words this
Queen is stopping Bishop development so
you have to harass this Queen and in
fact black did with the MU h5 no matter
we continue here with the move castle on
the Queen side his opponent indeed goes
with the MU H 4 and now white plays the
move Queen to history so at first sight
this green looks very funny because it's
completely upside and it is not
participating right now in the game but
as the game progressed you are going to
see how effective this Queen is now
black continue with his aggression with
the move b5 and it is very obvious that
black is just neglecting his King side
pieces and start attacking white on the
Queen side which I personally don't find
proper way because you are just
attacking with the Queen and against
twice 600 this is not going to work out
very well now what I'll do is I'll do an
exercise for you so I'll pause at 10
different positions of the game where
you have to identify vs move and if your
move match with the VA s move then give
yourself 10 points but if your mood
doesn't match with the VA s move then
just give 0 points at the end you have
to give yourself points from the hundred
get ready here is the first question
black is threatening the move B for what
you are going to do about it okay
I hope you find this wonderful move F
for the good point about the
tagging player is they never just go in
defensive mode they always look out for
the counter-attacking blow and in this
case this is perfectly set black
responded with the move Knight to c4 and
now no prize for guessing White's next
reply which is very obvious Bishop
captures and after Queen captures I
think black is in a horrible straight
look at the white all the PCs has been
developed and if you look at the black
the only piece black has developed is
Queen and it is very obvious that
something nasty is going to happen in
the black camp very soon okay now the
second important point I like you to
pause this video and find out as the
black is threatening the movie for now
how you going to respond to this move
congratulations if you find this
wonderful move fi see even super jeers
follow the basic rules of the chess so
the basic rule of the chess says that if
you are ahead in the development you
should open up the games so that way
your pcs have more freedom to join into
that deck now it is very obvious that
when you play moves such as f5 you have
to always calculate what happens if you
open in place move such as d4 oh well as
the black has not developed his pcs it
is very obvious that this move doesn't
create anything so I'll just give you a
sample line let's say while continue
here with the move Knight to e4 and if
black become greedy in capture the a to
pawn then after Knight to b6 attacking
to piece Callie note Queen to Haven
check is not deadly because I can always
escape with the MU Queen to d2
so black has to play moves such as rook
to b8 but after that I can simply reply
with the move Knight to b3 and including
King side piece development Black has
pathetic Queen posted on a - so what can
be the more disaster within the
okay so seeing that black decided to
continue his peace development with the
move Bishop to b7 still ignoring the
kingside development no matter white
continued here with the MU rook to have
fun so developing the last piece and
against b4 doesn't create any threats to
the white cam so black decided that if
the game will open then his king will be
in severe danger so he decided to close
the position with the move e5 and I
think this is the only wise move which
is played in the game here I continue
with the move Knight to b3 and now there
are some x-rays on d7 so for example any
casual moves by the black and leads to
disaster after the MU Epps's so wisely
enough black continued here with the
move Queen to c7 defending the d7 square
white played King to be even a
prophylactic move before the final
attack starts and now this is where the
things goes wrong where black plays the
move hope to see it and I think this is
too much ambitious because you are
completely ignoring your king side
pieces and you are going for an attack
which is not even create a mate so I
seriously have no idea what black is
doing right now okay now the third
important point I like you to pause this
video and find out how you going to
continue from here onwards well if you
see this move then you are really genius
because white played over here AB 6 can
you see that move what a wonderful move
now if the B 4 occurs at this point then
after pawn captures Bishop captures and
something similar happen which we are
about to see so instead of b4 black
decided that what's wrong with the
knight captures because not only its
developer piece but it's also defending
the d7 well this is a fourth question
and the ball is in your court how you
going to continue
I hope you find this dazzling mu rook
captures f6 boom ha ha ha
well such a sacrifice are bound to be
happen the simple reason is black is
completely underdeveloped and by playing
guru captures f6 first thing white has
done is to remove the defender of the d7
square here black doesn't have any
choice so black has to accept this and
after this the fifth question can you
find White's next reply okay I hope you
find this second dazzling move Bishop to
b6 a deflection boom as this Queen is
overloaded to protect this square it is
very obvious that black cannot capture
this piece so in other words black has
to move the Queen somewhere in the game
she decided to play the move Queen to c6
now white continuation is very obvious
white plays the another tacking move
that is Knight fi hitting the Queen one
more time and black decided to play
Queen to e6 and now I decided to simply
grab a piece and it's here that black
has some chances to come back in the
game it decided to do the Queen trade
that is let's say after Queen captures
pawn captures okay black has some worst
endgame but I think there are still some
chances but in the game it turns out
that when you are in attacking mode you
don't play sometimes the best move and
here black continue with the move rook
to b8 so his idea is to attack both the
piece but he missed a very important
reply by white so we reach to the sixth
position where you how to find the best
reply by the white okay I hope you find
this
wonderful move Knight to d5 the white
idea is very simple white is creating a
folk and black has to stop it can denote
the Queen exchange now it's impossible
the simple reason is let's say after
Queen captures but is threatening to
checkmate black King before I move on I
like you to pause this video and find
out how I can made black king okay I
hope you find this continuation that is
Knight to c7 check King to e7 Bishop to
c5 check d6 rope captures and now
however black plays for example let's
say a Phi then after Knight to d5
King to e8 Knight f6 check King to e7
and now the final blow
rook captures a6 and it's a checkmate
guys so it turns out that Queen capture
is impossible at this point so obviously
black has to find the other alternative
in the game she decided to continue with
the move rook captures b7 so her idea is
to if the knight check happens then
simply give up the rook but she
completely forgot that she is playing
against a genius we reach the seventh
critical position of the game I want you
to pause this video and find out the
best reply by the white yup its Queen to
c3 so the idea is back ring checkmate
and funny enough black doesn't have much
good resources exist in the game black
continue with his Queen dance that is
Queen to c6 but doesn't realize that ant
is very near
we need to the eighth critical position
of the game my question is how you are
going to continue okay I hope you find
this wonderful move Knight
to have sex check Kalli note if Queen
captures night then there is a mating
11:00 so I want you to find it by a hole
in the game black continue here with the
MU King to e7 no matter it's your turn
and I am sure that in this ninth
critical position you will find whites
next obvious response well well well
white has this Tesla Moo
well when first time I seen this game I
said wow what a game man this guy has
some serious attacking potential what to
do the problem over here is if the King
captures d8 then after the simple Queen
captures black is completely busted as
the d7 pawn is pin finally she decided
to play King to e6 and now this is a
10th and the last position I'm giving it
to you how you are going to finish the
blacking ok I hope you find this final
blow that is Queen to h3 and in fact
this is a checkmate what a wonderful
game that's it guys it's time to
calculate your points if you are scoring
70% or more than that then
congratulations you thinking just like
VA and you have a very good attacking
potential but if you're scoring less
than that then you are not looking at
the right direction and you seriously
need to improve your attacking chess
well I hope you enjoy and learn from
this superb attacking game by VA thank
you for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care
when you pay for game 10 he was so
pumped up it was frightening gone was
that warm greeting with Anand at the
start of the games here it was chilly he
didn't make any eye contact with Anand
at all instead of that that played a
move which looks very very attractive
and in fact giving up the Queen by Queen
cross C Phi